foreign
in Orlando Florida what's up Sam
how you doing doctor I'm good my brother
what's up
I need some help figuring out how to
tell my mom and brother that I want to
move out of my mom's house okay uh I'm
33 years old
um
actually kind of I'm embarrassed that
you know I live with her okay
um and I've just really been
I think I'm ready
I feel like I need to take take the
plunge okay
um
straight through all the way since you
were kid
[Music]
I've lived with her since I graduated
from college that was 2011. okay how
come you how come you stayed
well I really didn't have a like I had a
hard time like finding work and I
couldn't afford to you know to live on
my own
um you know so just kind of
you know did what I could you know you
know to get by
um you know recently I did a career
change uh you know I started working in
the uh it help desk you know then went
into I.T so hopefully to make a little
bit more money cool
um
yeah so can I ask you let me ask you
this brother
um and by the way I hope you hear it in
my voice I got no shame on this okay
I'm proud of you for being 33 and saying
Now's the Time okay and we could go
replay like what are you doing and where
are you babe why I'm not gonna do that
man I think the the best use of our
energy right now is what comes next
right moving forward
just listening to your voice for a few
seconds and just listen to you tell your
story about yourself
you don't think very highly of my new
friend Sam why not
why do you think Sam is is kind of a
loser
well you pretty much hit the you pretty
much hit the nail on the head
um where does that come from did your
mom talk to you like that
no uh absolutely not your brother
no neither one of them where does it
come from man
I guess it comes you know from myself I
guess I maybe I put pressure on myself
um you know I you know I've
you know
um
foreign
ER like you know it helped me uh get out
of you know get out of debt and help me
with my career change okay but I like
from what I understand it just seems
like like if you're at my age and you
live with your parents regardless of the
reason like you're a loser no that's
nonsense that's not true that is a part
of that story that you've you've kind of
morphed and taken in a really dark route
to tell yourself
okay I do think
uh I mean there's there's plenty of
people who live with their parents who
are helping out because their parents
are old age they've got health issues
um that move home for a season to like
pay their house off or to get out of
debt and then figure out what comes next
or they lose their job life happens life
happens
I would ask you as just your buddy dude
if you and I were just hanging out at a
bar having a beer I would ask you
hey it was hard to find work in 2011.
and fast forward it's 12 years later and
you're still telling yourself those same
stories
I can't find a job I'm not worth finding
a job I can't afford to live I just kind
of am and over the last 12 years you
have naturally
taking the easy path the hard path is
dude in six months I am moving out of
this apartment this house I'm getting my
own apartment and so I have to have this
much dollars which means I have to take
a second and third job or I Gotta Throw
my shoulders back a little bit
and commit to doing a bang-up job at
work and they're going to recognize me
and then in nine months they're going to
move me to this position I'm gonna move
to that position see what I'm saying so
something has held you back there and
um I'm glad to hear it's not your your
mom wouldn't tell calling you her loser
son and it wasn't your brother being
like Oh loser still like no man if
you've been helping out and taking care
of somebody who wasn't well or whatever
good for you good for you what has
brought you to this moment that like
this time I'm 33 it's time
uh well I wrote down uh some reasons to
leave and concerns that I have okay
um if that helps yeah so so the reasons
I want to leave
um I just think as Dave Ramsey put it
you know you never learn how to fly like
unless you read The Nest that's very
very true you there is a maturity
there is a growth and development
immaturity
um that you have not undergone because
you haven't had to there's something
about saying if I don't
earn this money I don't have a place to
live like there's some that builds
strength right if I don't push this bar
off my chest it will collapse my my ribs
right like there's some that's how you
grow strength right it's adding weight
on the bar and he is exactly one
thousand percent right
sir
uh I'm the only one in my Social Circle
that I know of who lives with who lives
with my mom correct uh
and
you know it's like my mom won't be
around forever I need to figure out like
how I'm going to sustain myself when she
leaves this world okay and also like I
feel guilty but it's like every other
weekend
uh more or less like she goes over to my
brothers and hangs out with her
grandkids
um I enjoy having a house you know to
myself you know you know she's like
retired
um you know she's a homebody and you
know we're around each other a lot and
Sam get your own place brother get your
own place
okay get your own place
you should feel nervous
you should feel angsty about it
you should do it with
um not uh do get a place you can afford
you're gonna feel a little bit lonely
it's gonna feel weird
and then have some of your buddies in
your Social Circle over on a regular
basis have Monday night whatever is at
your house
poker Nights video game nights dungeons
I don't know whatever nerd things people
what you're into I don't know
um like for me it would be like come
over and watch the fights or come over
and I don't know what things you're into
but
create a world where
your place becomes a place where people
hang out and it will develop very very
quickly
but it is time but I don't want you to
go because you're a loser now
like I'm the only guy I don't want that
to be the reason you go because Dave
Ramsey said I'm a loser if I don't want
that to be the reason you go even if
they're right
I want you to go because it's time for
the next chapter of your life
it's time for you to build the your the
next uh
to not build I want you to plant the the
roots that will become the next branch
of your family tree
mm-hmm
do you ever want to get married have
kids do that whole thing
yeah
yeah I'm not gonna lie man I don't see
myself having a wife and kids I mean not
not because of my current situation like
I see
I mean I see people with a wife and kids
and uh maybe it's my loner state of mind
but I don't see myself
uh you know being a husband and a dad
I won't take that from you what I will
tell you is
um
not not giving
um romantic relationships a shot
um is is robbing yourself of the deepest
and greatest Joys life has to offer
understood okay I can't put that on you
man if you want to not get married and
you want to live best or life your whole
life and not have kids cool
um in the same way you won't fully
understand the weight of maturity the
weight of growing up the way of being
adult until you got your own place
there's a deeper layer you won't truly
understand what love is what life is
about you won't truly understand what
you are capable of until you hold your
first kid
and you won't fully understand just how
terrifying and scary this place is
all of it right
and by the way if you're around a bunch
of people that are negative about their
wife and kids those people suck get new
friends all right get new people to hang
out with
um yes sir here's a here's a funny story
I think I've told it on the show before
but my friend my friend John
um we hung out every Monday night for
years and years and years me and him and
Todd and we hung out for years and years
and years and years and years
and then he had a kid and his wife is
awesome her name's Jen just absolutely
adores from my favorite people on the
planet but after like a year John
wouldn't hang out with us after he had
this new kid
and
I'm not gonna lie I was like man
Jennifer is the worst
she is not who like man I thought she
was super cool but he's got to stay home
all the time
and it wasn't until I had my son
that I realized I don't want to hang out
with those idiots I want to sit here on
my couch and hold my child or I want to
lay down on the floor and just stare
into his eyes
he can't even focus on me yet and I
asked John about that and he smiled and
he's like yeah no offense but I I would
rather be with my wife and kids and come
to find out Jennifer was like dude go be
with your friends get out of the house
and he was like no man I want to be with
you and the baby and I asked him why
didn't you ever tell me and he said man
I couldn't have explained that
I couldn't have explained that kind of
love I felt that's just something you
gotta experience so I tell you that to
tell you
um there is an intellectual side to it
but also man there is a part of your
heart and soul that will open up that
you will never understand
But to answer your question it's like
your original original question it
sounds like
you getting a friend that you trust
maybe your brother maybe even your mom
and you say it's time for me to move out
33 I'm gonna be 34 it's 20 23 is right
around the corner it's time for me to
move out here's my plan in three months
and five months whatever I'm gonna have
my own place and I'm gonna do Sunday
lunches I'd love y'all come over for
Sunday lunch
or whatever the thing is or once a month
I want to whatever your mom may go oh
thank God get out of my house or she
might be devastated right who knows yeah
that's that good that's one of my that's
that's like my concerns you know because
you know I'm not one of those guys who
just lives with her and doesn't
contribute you know I pay her rent yeah
no dude I'm not thinking that at all
yeah and like the only thing she says
that she does for me is put a roof over
my head and I just got done asking her
um hey does the monies I pay you really
hope and she says yes you don't know how
much yeah so it's like like I mean she
I mean we should be able to get by like
without me and so here's here's one of
the poisons of the way your mind works
okay Sam
is you think about a thing
and you do not seek out true data
you think about a thing and become
Paralyzed by the thoughts of that thing
and then you start trying to figure out
well if I do this then if I do that then
if I do that but then if I do that then
that's gonna happen then this is gonna
happen
and it's a deep deep seated pattern of
rumination that leads to paralysis
analysis paralysis and but you have it
times 10.
so the way through this is sitting down
with your mom saying mom it is time for
me to move out you mentioned the other
day that
um the money that I pay for rent is
really important to you I don't want to
leave you in a Lurch because I've been
here a decade now
right uh and it's by the way it's easy
to be like oh dude what a loser move out
on your own get your own play well now
you've established a life for your mom
too right so now you're you're into this
thing and so you have to leave
gracefully
um and so get firm data from your mom
mom can you survive
if I move out and establish my own name
my own place my own life and maybe one
day in my own family
um be very specific about the finances
okay dollar amounts not yeah I'll be
fine I want to see it where does your
income come from how would you pay these
bills how would you feel right that's
what I'm saying and it may be that she
moves in with you
she becomes a guest in your house do
what if that's the case then why I mean
I may as well stay with her then you
figure out a way to buy the house
because right now you're paying rent for
somebody else's home that you're gonna
have to split with your brother someday
then say cool I will purchase this home
and I will figure out my employment
situation I will save up I will do this
the right way uh not to further endanger
myself financially but I'm gonna buy
this house and you will be you will live
in my home
and just flip it on its script and that
would be a conversation with your
brother too
right or your brother can help
contribute as well say brother I've
given up all of my 20s and now I'm into
my 30s taking care of Mom living here
and I have it has been a great Advantage
for me but I'm also paying all of the
expenses and I'm ready to move out but
Mom can't afford to live by herself so
either she's got to move in with one of
us or we have to contribute to her
staying in this house what are you gonna
contribute
I hear you is it fair yes sir
are you gonna do any of this stuff
uh as soon as I get off this call I'm
gonna you know have this conversation
with her and ask her and just just you
know talk to her okay I would start that
conversation by
a few sons are as blessed as I have been
to had a mom who let me stay this long
and this is conversation one of a couple
of conversations but I want you to know
that it's time for me to find my own
place and I want to be very gracious in
how I do that but it's time
foreign
like on a note card on a piece of
notebook paper very specific we need to
talk about finances I won't leave you an
alert we need to figure out what comes
next you have where do you get money is
she on Social Security does she have a
pension who knows where she's getting
money but be very specific about that
stuff
um and then prepare for this to be
either a she cheers and goes finally
Sam's growing up get out or she's
devastated oh I'm not saying you can't
leave whatever
um and then be prepared to say okay cool
let's we're gonna let's just think on
this it's doing this I don't even know
what the apartments cost around here I
don't know what homes cost
um let's Circle back in Friday we'll
have second part of this conversation
and I'll bring brother too right and
we're gonna do this systematically and
the next three to six to nine months
whatever your financial situation is
let's plan to jump
let's plan to jump
unless it's gonna leave Mom destitute
and then you and brother sit down and
figure out together what your next steps
are
um
not gonna beat you up man
but your gut is right sounds like it's
time and so let's make a good solid plan
I'm gonna stop analyzing everything
let's move to action